Joon Lee: Okay.
Joon Lee: So who?
Joon Lee: Here's where I am.
Lucy Chen: basically.
Joon Lee: The story goes like… Pediatric health, or children's health,
Joon Lee: Among many other things, tracking their weight and height is the first
Joon Lee: Important tool to track their health.
Joon Lee: And we want them to grow.
Joon Lee: Healthy and normally, in quote, because
Joon Lee: How do we know they are growing normally compared to… what?
Joon Lee: And… That what?
Joon Lee: has been… the gross chart, Which was… Created using cross-sectional data.
Joon Lee: two decades ago, Using a surprisingly small number of data.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: And it has been… good tool…
Joon Lee: To roughly track where they are following the same percentile lines.
Joon Lee: Even if… Those lines were constructed from cross-sectional data, not tracking longitudinally.
Joon Lee: Now… That's good.
Joon Lee: We want to see whether they are falling off that percentile line.
Joon Lee: Due to unhealthy growth.
Joon Lee: And here comes our main problem.
Joon Lee: Unhealthy… So, deviation from expected line?
Joon Lee: could be pathological, signal?
Joon Lee: Or could be… any data error.
Joon Lee: and… Besides those completely impossible values outside the… upper, or… bottom… population distribution.
Joon Lee: When they are within that range, It's hard, or… Theoretically impossible to distinguish Pathological signal from data errors.
Joon Lee: And… If the kids… Gross trajectory is within that population upper-bottom bound.
Joon Lee: Then it's even harder, because the… deviations, Might be much smaller.
Joon Lee: And the smaller the deviation, harder to distinguish from errors.
Joon Lee: So there has been… Attempts and models or algorithms to use this longitudinal previous values
Joon Lee: To see how much variations there are, and then if it's…
Joon Lee: too much, then we say it might be error. But, still, Once the data is…
Joon Lee: Once measurement is done, and then saved into EHR,
Joon Lee: It's the end of the story.
Joon Lee: Because… There is no remeasurement possible.
Joon Lee: We cannot rewind kids two years back and then re-measure. It's gone-gone. From… once it's measured and entered and saved.
Joon Lee: it's done. From that point on, we don't know how much of an error or pathological signal
Joon Lee: is there. In many cases, probably it's a combination of both with different proportion.
Joon Lee: So, that's where we are, that's basically what we covered last week.
Joon Lee: on Friday.
Joon Lee: Boom.
Joon Lee: So I became very skeptical and…
Joon Lee: Critical on all of the published data or algorithms on data cleaning beyond, filtering out
Joon Lee: extreme values on… on either side. And there were papers saying, like, especially ex… Extreme z-score, weights.
Joon Lee: are actually signals. They tracked back and then checked again, and it was actually okay. So…
Joon Lee: even, like, z-scores of 4 or 5 was, act, like, real values.
Joon Lee: there are So, there's some, like, false pos… False… what is it?
Joon Lee: False positives, too.
Joon Lee: when we say positive is the error. So…
Joon Lee: But still, we can filter out, like, height of 20 centimeters, or, like, truly impossible values, so…
Joon Lee: Cleaning up.
Joon Lee: retrospectively, Overt… EHR… Height and weight measurement.
Joon Lee: I think it's an impossible problem to solve.
Lucy Chen: Mmm.
Joon Lee: Is that too strong?
Joon Lee: Maybe. Maybe. Maybe.
Lucy Chen: Oh, it's kind of because we don't have the… it's impossible to get the ground truth.
Joon Lee: Right.
Joon Lee: So that's actually the actual reason, even… trained pediatricians, cannot tell… Whether this small deviation, or…
Joon Lee: Quite big deviation is… Data error or pathological signal.
Joon Lee: It becomes a little bit more clear when that deviation Has some trend.
Joon Lee: But labeling it consistently, it's very hard.
Joon Lee: Maybe somewhere in between. Impossible then.
Joon Lee: So, there were some, like, Bayesian approach, like, Blah blah blah, but… At least, Labeling them, retrospectively.
Joon Lee: Very sketchy to me.
Joon Lee: if I'm… I don't know, if I'm the reviewer.
Joon Lee: I can't… I'm leaning towards reviewer 2's side more.
Joon Lee: Yeah.
Joon Lee: So… Not practically possible, but ideally, what should happen to have a gold standard ground truth data is
Joon Lee: having… Maybe 1,000 kids, or more than that.
Joon Lee: With equal proportion of healthy and pathological cases.
Joon Lee: Measure them at a set interval, maybe every month or every 3 months.
Joon Lee: Over… 18 years.
Joon Lee: And even during that measurement, There's a…
Joon Lee: last measurement alert, where it's too much deviation. It asks for second, maybe third, or
Joon Lee: Another different person measurement, and then save that together.
Joon Lee: But we cannot do this for 18 years. So practically, that's very… Impossible.
Joon Lee: So, 2 points, signal noise, Once it's recorded, saved to EHR data, It's… There's no way to…
Joon Lee: Definitely tell whether it's signal or noise, or What combination of…
Joon Lee: Noise is added to a signal, if it is a signal, actually, right?
Joon Lee: So, ground… getting ground-truth data is practically very, very hard, and… It's very easy to trick
Joon Lee: Our own algorithm works way better by adding a couple of
Joon Lee: places where it, it, we know it's working better. So, and… There are multiple… Publications where
Joon Lee: Inter-labeler consistency is very, very low, which we already saw.
Joon Lee: And it will get worse and worse.
Joon Lee: after re-adding… and more.
Joon Lee: data points to label, so…
Lucy Chen: Hmm.
Joon Lee: So, basically, Two or three different reasons, concrete reasons why getting ground truth is very, very hard.
Joon Lee: And once it's recorded, because remeasurement is non-option, for EHR data,
Joon Lee: It's really hard… oh, not hard, it's impossible to know whether it's pure signal, or pure error, or mix of both.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: Yeah.
Joon Lee: So,
Joon Lee: What's next?
Joon Lee: maybe from… Developing… Early detection algorithm perspective.
Joon Lee: We should just assume that signal and noise is mixed there, and it's hard to do
Joon Lee: Data cleanup, retrospective data cleaning.
Joon Lee: Hence… We just assume… that they're… errors embedded.
Joon Lee: And then develop an algorithm that's less sensitive to these algorithms.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: Yeah, I… is there anything else? I think that's…
Joon Lee: probably the best. And that's how Human Clinicians has been dealing with this for… many decades, anyways. You…
Joon Lee: They don't even… Like… pre-EHR error, it was actually… Plotted on a printed paper.
Joon Lee: So, there's already, like, a couple percentage up and down there, anyways.
Joon Lee: And I think it was more like…
Joon Lee: Not the actual calculation every time, you just plot
Joon Lee: weight… find the rough age. It's not always… on the… nth… Birthday, they are…
Joon Lee: We have clinics around that time, so you just… sometimes it's one month later, or 2 months later, so you just…
Joon Lee: plus somewhere, Between ages, and then…
Joon Lee: plot the height, or weight there. It's roughly.
Lucy Chen: there.
Joon Lee: So it… you never can tell, like, it's 57.2 percentile, or… or 58 percentile, that… yeah. It has been already, like, roughly, and then…
Joon Lee: It's… it… Looks like it's dark.
Joon Lee: Falling down, but when next year it may go back.
Joon Lee: If the same doctor saw that, then yeah, there might be something going on around, last year, But…
Joon Lee: It's back up to the same percentile line.
Joon Lee: Then they can say, might have been something going on, but looking at the same data.
Joon Lee: recorded in EHR, and we are looking at that.
Joon Lee: We cannot tell whether it was… Data error, or… actual biological
Joon Lee: process going on around that time, right? So… again.
Joon Lee: This has been there.
Joon Lee: Already. Forever.
Joon Lee: So… So I think mimicking that process, just accepting certain amount of error is present.
Lucy Chen: Mmm.
Joon Lee: And then developing a… good enough algorithm, I think it's the best we can do.
Lucy Chen: Hmm.
Lucy Chen: Well, I'm kind of curious, like, if, like, some of the supporting, like, matrix that we are using in error detection algorithm might, like, if we feed this matrix to, for example, like, Yonix program, project, maybe, like,
Lucy Chen: on top of…
Lucy Chen: On top of each record's, like, raw height and weight data, we provide the, height for HD score, we provide, like.
Lucy Chen: the, height change over age change, like this matrix, because sometimes LM might not, like, calculate these,
Lucy Chen: directly, so maybe providing these, like, I'm kind of curious how it might impact it.
Joon Lee: Do you wanna… do you wanna run… do you wanna write second paper on that, too? We can! I have, yes.
Joon Lee: No, I'm serious, like, if you want, we can pull something off.
Lucy Chen: within…
Joon Lee: Yeah, I don't know what your plan is.
Joon Lee: But… Yeah, but let's focus on this one first.
Lucy Chen: Mmm. Yeah.
Joon Lee: Yeah, so, actually, that was one of my initial…
Joon Lee: Plan, or less than plan, initial… one of the wish list items.
Joon Lee: Like, feeding same data, but in different format. Like, z-score, high velocity, delta, whatever, these are all derived information. It's basically height information, but feeding only height.
Joon Lee: like, here are Asian height, Asian height, Asian height, and then see what it tells, like, or tell it
Joon Lee: like, ask it to… to say Helcy on Nelsi, or healthy, or Chrome…
Joon Lee: Crohn's… What is it? Wow, haven't been saying this many times these days. It's all offloaded.
Joon Lee: One of those,
Joon Lee: gross disorders, whatever, and then give the same information with age, height, and z-score. Age, height, z-score.
Joon Lee: Run the same thing.
Joon Lee: Give it age, height, percentile, not z-score. Age, height, percentile. And then age, height.
Joon Lee: Percentile NZ score. Age height percentile Z score.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: run the whole thing. Age, height, percentile, z-score, and delta, or, the height velocity.
Joon Lee: And then see what, what it's doing.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: because…
Joon Lee: Can you imagine there? These LMs are actually taking… if we feed 20 height measurements, it actually converts them
Joon Lee: to these scores using CDC growth chart, LMS values, and dude, I… I don't think so!
Joon Lee: And, if you just give… Female, 13 years old, forfeit 2 inches.
Joon Lee: What's the height percentile? That's the whole prompt.
Joon Lee: Give it to… Gemini, Claude, Grog,
Joon Lee: ChatGPT. You'll be amazed. You'll laugh a lot. They're all different.
Lucy Chen: I think I… I think I tried… I think I might have tried something similar to that. Like, back… back at the time I tried it, it was not giving… it was not… definitely not calculating the C-score correctly.
Joon Lee: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Joon Lee: and… It's only quite close and looks like it's correct when you give height for 50 percentile.
Joon Lee: If it's… away from 50 percentile line, it's using the normal distribution z-score calculation.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: Not calculation, I think it's assuming that, and then using a… some kind of z-score table, and then extrapolate… interpolate.
Joon Lee: between those values, but even that is wrong. They're not using the LMS distribution.
Lucy Chen: This.
Joon Lee: Anyways, I… yeah, they're… no, they cannot do the calculation as an LLM. If they do correctly, it's using
Joon Lee: like, gross chart, z-score, calculation.
Lucy Chen: Tours.
Joon Lee: tools, yeah.
Lucy Chen: Mmm.
Joon Lee: Yeah.
Joon Lee: So that was… that was one thing I wanted to do.
Joon Lee: Second part is actually feeding the image version directly.
Lucy Chen: Oh…
Joon Lee: Because that's what… what… Humans have been doing.
Lucy Chen: But…
Joon Lee: Probably, I don't think it was trained with all different variations. It probably saw a couple of…
Joon Lee: images appearing in medical textbooks or journal articles as an image, so probably… not that impressive, I guess?
Joon Lee: But… If you're ambitious, or can… Train an open-source model using Our 250,000 gross.
Lucy Chen: trumps.
Joon Lee: only image.
Lucy Chen: Oh, that's… that sounds like a very interesting project.
Joon Lee: Right? Right.
Joon Lee: I mentioned this, maybe last year, October, or something like that.
Lucy Chen: Oh, wow.
Joon Lee: This one is more interesting, right? It's a… Then… How do we… promote this.
Joon Lee: paper. We can say, this… this… This model… is…
Joon Lee: Is or will be used in, iPhone or Android app, for parents.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: And they can just take picture
Joon Lee: Or the growth chart at the clinic, when the doctor shows you.
Joon Lee: graph. And then, right away, they can tell whether
Joon Lee: The doctor missed something or not.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: I don't know.
Joon Lee: What's your guess that, like, Dad… I'm actually 50-50. This… custom… Trained model with images.
Joon Lee: may work… Could work better than feeding table of Measurements in text.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: Because this image model is… trained on… like…
Joon Lee: less precise, like, image version. Already, it is converted to… to a… like…
Joon Lee: from precise numbers to a graph with a line, so…
Lucy Chen: Mmm.
Joon Lee: I don't know.
Joon Lee: There could be another exciting… Project, where you actually feed
Joon Lee: After the first, experiment. Oh, actually, feeding age, height, and percentile works best.
Joon Lee: Actually, it's worse giving it z-score, or z-score and percentile, just give these three. I don't know, but somehow one of those variations may turn out to be better.
Joon Lee: Then… We use that format.
Joon Lee: Train a new open model.
Lucy Chen: using.
Joon Lee: 250,000 cases.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: It should work, right?
Lucy Chen: And it sounds… it sounds really interesting.
Joon Lee: Okay.
Lucy Chen: promising.
Joon Lee: Yeah, I'm open, Zach is open, if you want to. Yeah.
Joon Lee: Yes.
Joon Lee: I'll just throw out another, information I got. I think it was published 2 or 3 weeks ago.
Joon Lee: I'm not sure about the publication date. It was…
Joon Lee: recent, but I found it 2-3 weeks ago. Somebody… Oh… fed… medication list.
Joon Lee: To… Small models with, like, 7 billion parameters up to, like, 70 billion parameters, like, open models.
Joon Lee: And, feed it, the fire.json object?
Lucy Chen: Mmm.
Joon Lee: And… Ayy.
Joon Lee: summarize, like… extracted some, text version, only…
Joon Lee: listing out medication name and date, prescription date, and those. Because fires have had lots of tags and, like.
Joon Lee: Like, all sorts of… unrelated metadata there.
Lucy Chen: Mmm.
Joon Lee: what's your guess? Which one works better? Already, I gave you too much hint, but… yeah.
Lucy Chen: Good.
Joon Lee: It turns out.
Joon Lee: Text version?
Joon Lee: No, actually… For a smaller model, 7 billion parameters, text version works much better.
Lucy Chen: -Oh.
Joon Lee: Over 70 billion parameter models.
Joon Lee: Giving the raw… raw… Oh.
Joon Lee: Fireform JSON works better.
Lucy Chen: Oh…
Joon Lee: Probably because they were trained with lots of JSON text.
Lucy Chen: Files…
Joon Lee: And, and… so… It knows the structure.
Joon Lee: So this was with the medication list, and they checked whether certain medication, like, all the medication listed, like, included in the fire bundle is all present, or any one of them were missed, so…
Joon Lee: Bait… But we don't know what would happen with these data, so…
Joon Lee: We can do that experiment, too. There's so many things we can.
Lucy Chen: You can track.
Joon Lee: Yeah.
Lucy Chen: Hmm.
Joon Lee: So… I wonder how… how our transcript will be summarized, but back to the original discussion.
Joon Lee: I think… If we… Describe the story.
Joon Lee: from, like, signal to noise, and then that's what, like, we want to get the signal, we want to distinguish signal from noise, like, pathological signal versus data error. However, once it's recorded, measured, and recorded in EHR, when it's
Joon Lee: exported as a longitudinal data, there's no way to tell that.
Lucy Chen: Mmm.
Joon Lee: Whether it's signal or noise.
Joon Lee: That's one major point there. Hence…
Lucy Chen: Hmm.
Joon Lee: We're not… we… be very clear up front. We're not proposing a new data
Joon Lee: cleaning algorithm. There are many…
Joon Lee: successful publication out there, but this paper is not such… not proposing that. We're proposing only the, last data or new measurement
Joon Lee: alert.
Joon Lee: algorithm, based on basically your… your approach. I think…
Joon Lee: That just makes sense. There are these data points, and then then… Previous values are like this.
Joon Lee: There's a… plausible distribution around here, where the new data should be, right? Even… even if there's
Joon Lee: well, that's… that's the whole… whole point. It's… versus, somebody else having these previous values, then it will…
Joon Lee: Be somewhere, somewhere in this, this,
Joon Lee: this range, right? That's basically your z-score on that specific point, right? What… what…
Joon Lee: What's the D-score of having this value,
Joon Lee: In that point. That was one of your metrics.
Joon Lee: Besides the population z-score.
Lucy Chen: You mean, like, the velocity? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
Joon Lee: So, we just say, this is a very simple method, alerting for remeasure if it's falling too much away from expected value.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: then I think it's… it's… it's… clear. It's positively trashing existing…
Joon Lee: retrospective data cleaning algorithm. We should say, why we came to this, like, include, like, why making ground truth is very, very hard, and give a…
Joon Lee: very simple. I don't know how…
Joon Lee: Whether it's simple enough to be included in the paper, but
Joon Lee: How easy it is to trick.
Joon Lee: The ground truth data so that one algorithm works Way better.
Joon Lee: Then.
Lucy Chen: There was… just by…
Joon Lee: By swapping out a couple of, ground-throughs labeling.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: Yeah. So…
Joon Lee: Signal noise, once recorded, it's impossible to distinguish afterwards, and then coming up with the ground truth data is also very impost… very hard.
Lucy Chen: Hmm.
Joon Lee: consensus very low. We can cite a couple of papers out there. There were papers, like, some…
Joon Lee: community public health effort in Africa, where they, trained
Joon Lee: many volunteers to measure, height and weight, and then dispatch them to different villages, and then, they did some research on the data quality, and even for trained
Joon Lee: people there were variations
Joon Lee: By the same person. So… and, and, younger ages, based on their posture, or…
Lucy Chen: Hmm.
Joon Lee: Whether it's in the morning or in, late in the evening, there is even biological variations, too. So,
Joon Lee: Like, health… like, healthy, Biological variations during the day, plus pathological pathological variations, plus, data, or measurement.
Joon Lee: Error or variations, and data entry error.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: There were a couple papers, I can find it back, there were papers describing, like, taxonomy of errors, or, like.
Lucy Chen: Mmm.
Joon Lee: Yeah, in this measurement. I'm seeing, like.
Lucy Chen: Goodbye.
Joon Lee: We can mention that, and then, okay, hey, from…
Joon Lee: This paper going forward, don't… don't publish this kind of paper.
Joon Lee: I mean, not direct, but directly saying that, but if…
Joon Lee: our readers read through and then think that, like, oh, this totally makes sense, I'm not trying
Joon Lee: You know, like, labeling or,
Joon Lee: Coming up with, with, what the…
Joon Lee: simulated data set. Simulated data set, we didn't say anything. Again, what does it mean?
Joon Lee: Simulating, like, adding noise there?
Lucy Chen: I think, like, Harold's, I think it's, they are creating a simulated population data, and then, adding noise to, like, simulated, errors to the original population.
Joon Lee: Wow, so they used two simulations.
Joon Lee: Multiplied, and then still got published, so… Yeah.
Joon Lee: makes even less sense to me now, so… yeah. Basically.
Joon Lee: Elegantly describing this in the introduction, and then, proposing
Joon Lee: New measurement or re-measurement alert system, yeah.
Joon Lee: That's what I've been thinking.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: And it's your turn now. You can't completely disagree or.
Lucy Chen: No, I think it totally makes sense.
Joon Lee: So…
Joon Lee: We can still use, multiple methods, like… and you actually use multiple methods, using the gross chart data to filter out extreme values, so that…
Joon Lee: Should happen anyways, but this is…
Joon Lee: That… that's not the point. It's when the… the…
Joon Lee: Possible measurement error is within the very possible range,
Joon Lee: With impossible range.
Joon Lee: Right. Oh.
Joon Lee: One paper was mentioning outliers?
Joon Lee: as… Like, population outliers.
Joon Lee: extreme z-score values on… Plus and minus side.
Joon Lee: And then… inliers.
Joon Lee: Where it's within possible population, Distribution.
Joon Lee: Like, plus, minus… busy score 2 or even 1, but if you look at the longitudinal
Joon Lee: trajectory of one patient, it doesn't make sense. It's too much deviation. So, that they…
Joon Lee: named it as inlier, so.
Lucy Chen: It's in.
Joon Lee: liar within population, but it's a…
Joon Lee: Less plausible or, like, outlier from that one patient's longitudinal trajectory perspective.
Lucy Chen: I think.
Joon Lee: That's a good naming, I think.
Joon Lee: Yeah, we're proposing remeasurement alert system.
Joon Lee: Where it takes care of, longitudinal measurement, and then, if it's…
Joon Lee: Above certain threshold of possible,
Joon Lee: Distribution based on the longitudinal values, will… Alert.
Joon Lee: Or we can output, like… Confidence… Or…
Joon Lee: what's a good name? Basically, how… how confident are we That it's a… Error?
Joon Lee: I think this… this phrasing should be elegantly done. Like, we say, we're confident, like, we're…
Joon Lee: more than X percent confident for remeasurement or something.
Lucy Chen: something like that.
Joon Lee: But basically, the output should be re-measured, and the… Whatever, confidence score there.
Joon Lee: Yeah, yeah.
Joon Lee: then I think it will have a very good chance to be published.
Lucy Chen: Hmm…
Joon Lee: Maybe, maybe even to some…
Joon Lee: good pediatric journals, because they did… like, there are so many biosticians trying to come up with this new algorithm over and over, and…
Joon Lee: And, yeah.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: That's how I've been… I've been thinking. I think I Everything.
Joon Lee: So… What's next? We have… we have one week. I guarantee, based on my own… Experience?
Joon Lee: For myself, two kids, many…
Joon Lee: other students, once you graduate, your brain completely changes, and suddenly you lose steam. Probably you, you, you… you can easily expect that, too.
Lucy Chen: Yeah, yeah.
Joon Lee: Yeah, so… If this is not…
Joon Lee: Hi, Don.
Joon Lee: Before your graduation, probably you're… you're losing one nice publication with Harvard names there, so…
Joon Lee: What, what, are you interested in joining, like,
Joon Lee: Frontier Labs directly working on LLMs?
Lucy Chen: Like, right now, or…
Joon Lee: I mean, in the fu- like, near future, or… Or…
Lucy Chen: Joe.
Joon Lee: Just, just having a stable… job at Google is enough, and you'll start enjoying your life.
Lucy Chen: For now, maybe… maybe, like, still, like, stable job at Google, maybe.
Joon Lee: I, I mean, that, that's… that's…
Joon Lee: That's probably a wiser choice. I… I…
Joon Lee: I have two boys in complete… two extremes.
Joon Lee: Like, one is so laid back, and…
Joon Lee: He's saying he doesn't know what to do in the future. The other one is… Like…
Joon Lee: super ambitious all the time, from, like, from 5, 6.
Lucy Chen: success.
Joon Lee: 7 years old, like… Doing pretty much
Joon Lee: All different competition, like, mass competition, like…
Lucy Chen: Trevor competition.
Joon Lee: Like, like, whatever. Like, whatever gives you a ranking.
Lucy Chen: Well…
Joon Lee: But, I don't know whether it's, it's, it's…
Joon Lee: That is the good thing, like…
Lucy Chen: Meaning.
Joon Lee: He's more under stress.
Joon Lee: He's… he's… he's, squeezing himself all the time. The other one is…
Joon Lee: Reading Harry Potter again, like… For the, like, seventh time, like…
Lucy Chen: I don't know.
Joon Lee: Watching that play. It's good life!
Lucy Chen: That's me when… that's me when I was young.
Joon Lee: I mean, it's… it's good, it's good.
Joon Lee: So, anyways, reason I'm telling you this is, like, looks like these Frontier Labs Loves these,
Joon Lee: machine learning or AI-related, publications, so… that… in your…
Joon Lee: possible wish list. Having a paper who will give you…
Lucy Chen: I'm sure.
Joon Lee: Quite some edge to all other candidates, so…
Joon Lee: Well, you, you expressed quite some excitement when I was telling you about those LLM experiments.
Lucy Chen: Yeah, I'm… yeah, these are, like, interesting.
Lucy Chen: Interesting.
Lucy Chen: care… care about it.
Lucy Chen: If it was, like… Two years ago, when I just joined, I definitely want you to…
Joon Lee: Participate. So I think curiosity is there in your heart, but, same thing with me,
Joon Lee: Reading Science Nature Journal.
Joon Lee: It's so fun.
Joon Lee: But… I don't want to spend, like, 5 years
Joon Lee: In the lab, like, dissect… dissecting, like, mouse brain, like.
Lucy Chen: I don't know.
Joon Lee: Ended up, like, tiny, like this, like, 2,000 mouse brain, and…
Joon Lee: Yeah, like, yeah, curiosity from, like, actually…
Joon Lee: on, like, solving that thing myself, it's two separate things, so… yeah, you can still be very curious.
Joon Lee: curious person, loving science, all that, but doesn't mean that you need to do that directly. Yeah, so…
Joon Lee: I mean, Y-you… you have pretty much everything. Maybe a couple things we… Can add here is,
Joon Lee: What should be the results?
Joon Lee: Besides the code itself, I guess the… the…
Joon Lee: The threshold itself is… it's arbitrary thresholds, so,
Joon Lee: Proposing a method how to decide the threshold based on your need.
Joon Lee: That could be one of the results.
Lucy Chen: Hmm…
Joon Lee: Because,
Joon Lee: If this is actually… included in an EHR.
Joon Lee: Does it have same issue as, these many, Clinical decision support algorithms, where
Joon Lee: Even small percentage of false positives
Joon Lee: Makes the clinician just start ignoring that.
Joon Lee: So I guess… My hunch is,
Joon Lee: It can have a little bit higher false positive rates.
Joon Lee: Than those diagnostic algorithms.
Lucy Chen: Mr.
Joon Lee: just… Hey! Are you sure? Let's measure one more time.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: Is it asking too much to the nurses?
Joon Lee: I don't know.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: Or is there any way we can… Run this algorithm…
Joon Lee: Feeding only up to a certain point, and then…
Joon Lee: Character is how many of them are… alerted?
Joon Lee: at different threshold. I think that's one graph we can include.
Joon Lee: Yeah.
Joon Lee: Or,
Joon Lee: Or, now that we are just proposing remeasurement algorithm, we just…
Joon Lee: Accept whatever synthetic data, or our own data, run their algorithm, and then just simply
Joon Lee: See… report how many of them are…
Joon Lee: How many of them will be alerted
Joon Lee: with different threshold. We just report that. And which threshold you choose, it's up to you. Basically, it's…
Lucy Chen: it's…
Joon Lee: It's kind of RSC curve.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: With sensitivity and specificity and…
Joon Lee: And we just include certain quick calculation, like typical pediatric clinic.
Joon Lee: Sees, N patients, so…
Joon Lee: With this threshold, the additional burden Might be, like…
Joon Lee: 5 measurement, additional re-measurement a day, or something like that.
Lucy Chen: just beginning.
Joon Lee: Include that as a…
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: And future direction, we hope this is actually deployed and,
Joon Lee: One, the data quality.
Joon Lee: plus… Re-measure… remeasurement rate.
Joon Lee: is actually… Collected and, yeah.
Lucy Chen: in a life.
Joon Lee: In the future, something like that.
Lucy Chen: Mmm.
Joon Lee: Oh, I love this paper, actually.
Joon Lee: Yeah.
Lucy Chen: Mmm… Let me just write that down.
Joon Lee: Yeah, I… Yeah, take the transcript, and then…
Lucy Chen: Mmm.
Joon Lee: Download the VTT, and then, yeah.
Joon Lee: Yeah, that has been working really well. I loved it. That's why I'm so talkative today. Yeah, so…
Joon Lee: Are you too dead?
Joon Lee: Get it organized in your brain, and then… I start writing an abstract.
Joon Lee: Or ask it to convert it to abstract.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: Yeah, dope.
Joon Lee: Or you can even start with, give me a, prompt to…
Joon Lee: evaluate a given abstract. It will come up with a nice criteria.
Lucy Chen: Mmm.
Joon Lee: Yeah. Read the prompt, the evaluation prompt… it generated…
Joon Lee: And if it makes sense, use it. If it doesn't make sense, ask it to include or exclude certain criteria there. You can add it, like, this is, evaluating a,
Joon Lee: Biomedical, journal article abstract, or something like that, blah blah blah.
Joon Lee: Yeah. And then, based on this criteria, Use this transcript, write a… S-tra, or something like that.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: We don't have much time left.
Joon Lee: It's like, you'll… you will die as a…
Joon Lee: As a researcher in a week.
Lucy Chen: Hmm.
Joon Lee: Literally. Yeah.
Lucy Chen: I would try to get it in.
Joon Lee: Yeah, so…
Lucy Chen: Hmm.
Joon Lee: Do that, and then, come up with…
Joon Lee: Figure 1, 2, maybe up to 5.
Joon Lee: Figure or table 1 to 5.
Joon Lee: List.
Lucy Chen: Mmm, mmm, okay.
Joon Lee: We can have, I don't know, do we even need to?
Joon Lee: List out existing algorithms.
Joon Lee: Probably not.
Joon Lee: So come up with, what… what should be included in the tape… in the paper. Maybe we don't need that many figures, but…
Joon Lee: Up to a figure… Table figure… 4, probably. 4 or 5.
Lucy Chen: Hmm, okay. Yeah.
Joon Lee: Less than that is fine, too.
Lucy Chen: Hmm.
Joon Lee: I have about… 20, 30, pDFs on… Data cleaning?
Joon Lee: algorithms?
Joon Lee: and issues around that, I'll… What's the best way?
Joon Lee: Maybe… It's all added to Zotero, the shared one.
Joon Lee: But I didn't edit any… tags there.
Lucy Chen: Hmm…
Joon Lee: Let me… Let me do that. I think many of them should be included in the paper.
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: Let's do this. I'll… I'll,
Joon Lee: Oh… share a,
Joon Lee: Not having much time is actually a huge gift, because you become very, very selective on
Joon Lee: Every decision to not waste any time.
Joon Lee: Oh.
Joon Lee: I'll add a tag in the share Zotero and share with you.
Lucy Chen: Bye.
Joon Lee: And maybe, if it helps, I can… share…
Joon Lee: the PDFs, only those PDFs in…
Joon Lee: one place, I can upload them to… GitHub private repository, too.
Joon Lee: So…
Lucy Chen: Mmm…
Joon Lee: Yeah, I'll do something, I'll do… I'll share that very soon. I… I… have,
Joon Lee: mark down exports of all these PDFs.
Joon Lee: And used, Codecs to… go through… all the paper and summarize.
Joon Lee: Well, that one…
Joon Lee: Sure, no.
Joon Lee: So I've been having quite some fun while you're… Source… And,
Joon Lee: directory has Lucy in the name. Okay, right here.
Joon Lee: I don't think I… Shared this with you, but… We can feed this one.
Joon Lee: Along with our… Today's meeting transcript there.
Joon Lee: That one is… Probably one week away from
Joon Lee: my thinking today. So, it might be still… Trying on the…
Joon Lee: Coming up with the… This is called,
Joon Lee: Coming with the ground truth data, or ground truth data labeling perspective a little bit.
Lucy Chen: Hmm…
Joon Lee: Yeah.
Joon Lee: Oh.
Joon Lee: Okay, this one is… Actually, yeah, I'll share it here, but I'll share the whole directory.
Lucy Chen: to get.
Joon Lee: Cot.
Joon Lee: That's the easiest.
Joon Lee: It has a, friday meeting transcript that… that you missed.
Lucy Chen: I'm dumb.
Joon Lee: That discussion summary is, basically…
Joon Lee: All you need, you don't need to read the discussion, the actual transcript.
Lucy Chen: Hmm.
Joon Lee: Mr.
Joon Lee: Yeah, okay.
Joon Lee: Diff… Good plan. Your life will… you only have, like, 7 days of life.
Lucy Chen: Let me, go over it, and then… Yeah.
Lucy Chen: help me check if, the plan is good. Yeah. So I have, first, maybe, so use the HERO simulated data, to…
Lucy Chen: Actually, let me, think up there a little bit.
Joon Lee: I would do this.
Joon Lee: So, select maybe… are using Harold's data.
Lucy Chen: Oh, because that's what I used for the… the evaluation.
Joon Lee: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucy Chen: In the new court.
Joon Lee: Yeah.
Lucy Chen: So maybe using that simulated data, and then try, like, count how many, how many…
Lucy Chen: Should we call it, like, true positive phosphorus.
Joon Lee: No, no, no.
Lucy Chen: Or…
Joon Lee: I would just, not say it's error or not an error.
Lucy Chen: Just constant…
Joon Lee: Your algorithm spits out some score.
Joon Lee: Right?
Lucy Chen: The confidence score…
Joon Lee: Yeah.
Lucy Chen: I think I deleted that in the final version, but I can… I can, I can get it back, just, like, make another, like, confidence score.
Joon Lee: If it's easy, easy enough. If it, if it can be done within 7 days. Because, I'm trying to avoid…
Joon Lee: like… labeling, dispute, or whatsoever. We just spit out a confidence score.
Joon Lee: And then call it an error or not, or alerting remeasure or not decision is purely based on which threshold the user is choosing.
Joon Lee: That we don't, we don't need to defend much.
Lucy Chen: So, so each of the matrix itself might have some, like, thresholds, like, for example, like, the velocity, maybe, the velocity is based on,
Lucy Chen: plus or minus 3… 3C, or, if it's over 3Z, or if it's over 4D, over 5C, the velocity has, threshold itself, and then the other one, the, like, the original z-score has also has threshold, do we, like.
Lucy Chen: Compile, like, for example.
Joon Lee: opposite score.
Lucy Chen: Yeah, and then…
Joon Lee: Yeah.
Lucy Chen: And then the user just choose, if the error comp… like, error confidence is over 80% we alert, or over 70% we alert. So we don't worry about, the…
Lucy Chen: The original threshold.
Lucy Chen: We only worry about the final score.
Joon Lee: So, I would do quick… LLM search.
Joon Lee: what I'm sure there must be already Hundreds of papers on
Joon Lee: making compass score from exit… multiple z-score, even… yeah.
Joon Lee: So, let's just… just… it might be just…
Joon Lee: averaging them out, or whatever, I don't know what… what… yeah. There might be already many studies on that.
Lucy Chen: So you still…
Joon Lee: Add one score, and then we just give… calculate
Joon Lee: that threshold for each point on Harold's data, And,
Joon Lee: Based on different thresholds, we report how many of them are alerted it for remeasure.
Lucy Chen: Mmm.
Joon Lee: And then, for different scores, the number will change.
Joon Lee: And we can…
Joon Lee: We can have a table… that simply… tells…
Joon Lee: How many of the so-called data error in that
Joon Lee: That simulated data set was report, like, alerted for remeasure.
Lucy Chen: occasion onion.
Joon Lee: So Harold's data have, like, they say they in, like, in.
Lucy Chen: Deuce.
Joon Lee: error, so they know which one is an error.
Joon Lee: And they say, That one is true positive, right?
Lucy Chen: So…
Joon Lee: We just calculate all the data points.
Joon Lee: And then see, at a given threshold, how many of these true positives were
Joon Lee: actually alerted for remeasure. And maybe we can find the threshold where 100% of the injected errors are
Joon Lee: reported for remeasure, and then…
Joon Lee: In that threshold, how many of the, like, non-errors were included as false positive?
Lucy Chen: Mmm. Right.
Joon Lee: It… yeah.
Joon Lee: But, so it's basically a RSC curve.
Lucy Chen: Mmm.
Joon Lee: Right? Yeah.
Lucy Chen: Okay.
Joon Lee: Yeah, yeah.
Joon Lee: And then we call it a day, and you go to graduation, and bye-bye.
Lucy Chen: I can do this, I can do this.
Joon Lee: Yeah, you already have pretty much everything here, yeah.
Lucy Chen: Yeah.
Joon Lee: Yeah, yeah.
Lucy Chen: Hmm.
Lucy Chen: Yeah, I should be able to give that to you… Tomorrow.
Lucy Chen: So tomorrow, I… I need to take a vaccine. Maybe tomorrow night, or the day after tomorrow.
Joon Lee: I'm trying to save you. I'm not trying to squeeze you out.
Lucy Chen: Yeah, I always… I think, yeah, it should be… yeah, it depends if I think for the vaccine, because… because I… sometimes I…
Lucy Chen: sometimes I pass out after taking the vaccine for, like, a few minutes.
Joon Lee: Yeah, I mean…
Lucy Chen: official would be, but hopefully I don't.
Joon Lee: My wife is, Either more sensitive, or…
Joon Lee: It is more sensitive to pretty much any medication, so, usually, if she's taking…
Joon Lee: the same amount for adults in that bottle? Like, it's too strong.
Lucy Chen: Usually, yeah.
Joon Lee: Yeah, yeah, so… Yeah, I'm taking almost twice.
Joon Lee: But… Yeah.
Joon Lee: I mean, it's good that you're responding directly to medications. Yeah. But, no, no, no, I mean, it's really up to you. Yeah, whatever…
Joon Lee: Yeah.
Lucy Chen: Hmm, okay.
Joon Lee: So, pull me in, I'm… I'm… yeah, yeah.
Joon Lee: But after this meeting, I'll push the Git repository and add, like, add you to that. It'll be…
Lucy Chen: Okay.
Joon Lee: Yeah.
Lucy Chen: Huh.
Joon Lee: I'm quite hopeful, it's, it's very possible within a week.
Lucy Chen: Yeah.
Joon Lee: Yeah.
Joon Lee: Yeah. Sounds good. Sounds like you're a little bit suspicious on that, but let's see.
Lucy Chen: Boom!
Joon Lee: Yeah, okay.
Lucy Chen: Hmm…
Joon Lee: It was a good, good one-hour meeting.
Joon Lee: Yeah, ask it to organize it by topic, and then you can read it through, and then just copy-paste things together.
Joon Lee: A little bit, and then turn this into abstract, blah blah blah, turn this into introduction, all… yeah, I'll do well.
Joon Lee: Okay, see you soon.
Lucy Chen: Okay, see you!
Joon Lee: Yep, good night.
Lucy Chen: Okay, good night.